le conseil départemental et le conseil
régional avait invité la communauté
indienne et toute la réunion à célébrer
le nouvel an tamoul
une fête qui a commencé par faire
résonner les tambours sacrés sur la
place ramgoolam invité d'honneur de
cette célébration
le consul de l'inde arrivé tout
récemment dans l'ue les élus et les
officiels se sont ensuite rendus à
l'intérieur du jardin de l'état
décorée aux couleurs de l'inde pour
l'occasion des invités en public qui ont
pu assister à l'impressionnante danse du
jacquot pour présents tentent de la
présidente nassimah dindar la vice
présidente nadia ramassamy a rappelé à
quel point il était important pour les
deux collectivités de célébrer le vivre
ensemble réunionnais à travers les
festivités du jour de l'an tamoul
il me semble d'abord essentiel de
rappeler à l'heure où certains décompose
dangereusement la réunion en communauté
le sens que le conseil départemental
comme la révolution nous apportons à la
célébration de la nouvelle année comme
du reste aux autres fêtes dites
communautaires
il ne s'agit pas de diviser mais au
contraire de rassembler ce que je
souhaite une très très bonne
la communauté tamoule de la réunion le
président didier robert a appelé pour sa
part la fierté de cette réunion aux
multiples racines de messages le premier
c'est qu'il faut que l'on continue à
cultiver notre vivre ensemble et que
l'on prenne bien conscience tous les uns
et les autres que c'est un travailleur
ensemble en avançant qu ensemble que
nous réussirons à mieux construire cette
réunion à laquelle nous sommes attachés
le deuxième message c'est être fiers
être fiers de ce que nous sommes être
fiers de notre parcours être fiers de ce
qu'ils nous ont précédés et avoir
suffisamment d'audace et d'ambition dont
chacun d'entre nous pour que chaque
réunionnais trouve sa place
également présent les conseillers
départementaux et vice-président ou
jacques morel et marie-paule balaïa west
ham et saveurs comme interviennent à
mort pour leur prêter mais heureuse
année remplie de chance pour eux mêmes
et leurs familles
c'est une bonne année à la réunion
ces peuples nous est commune
delarue ça renforce nos peuples
sacrée entre nous
rien de fraternité fait sommes tout
d'abord nous sommes
et en lui confiant la communauté tamoule
dans l'île il est très important de
mettre en avant aussi notre douleur
notre religion et notre façon de vivre
et à ce propos donc je souhaite quand
même une très bonne année à tous la
communauté tamoule de la réunion en
particulier à la communauté tamoule de
st pierreville dans laquelle je suis né
et la communauté tamoule de saint paul
la ville de coeur pour des raisons
personnelles
saint-andré la ville du maire jean paul
virapoullé qui est souligné l'importance
de promouvoir l'homme réunionnais dans
toute sa diversité
une vision de tolérance partagées par le
consul belote
j'en ai célébré deux autres tamouls il
arrive de temps en temps mais nous avons
façon de réconcilier les cultures entre
elles nous avons le privilège de me
souhaiter bonne année
cette bande là chinois on années quand
cette fois 30 à moules et 12 filles
c'est la fin du ramadan et puis bonne
année au 31 décembre et
non seulement c'est un privilège de se
souhaiter bonne année chaque fois mais
ça finit par créer des liens solides de
fraternité et ce vibrant
le nez est la pépite de la société
rumeurs
j'aime l'unité la diversité présente ici
toutes ces communautés ces religions ces
différentes couleurs de peau toutes ces
cultures qui vivent ensemble
paisiblement
c'est quelque chose de très bien qu'ils
représentent ce que l'inde et la réunion
ont en commun une réunion multiples
facettes avec la culture indienne mise à
l'honneur mais également de nombreux
spectacles qui ont jalonné cette belle
soirée aux mille couleurs
et